what's up guys it's mkbhd and today i'm
going to be telling you guys why oled
technology rocks don't you know so start
with how the technology works basically
instead of having one single backlight
for all the pixels each individual pixel
lights up so if you need green on this
one pixel the pixel can turn green and
if you need blue on this pixel that
pixel can turn blue if it needs to
display black instead of lighting up the
pixel it just doesn't light it up at all
and this means three awesome things
number one this saves energy that would
have been used to light the pixels which
means better battery life and that's why
oled displays are great for
battery-powered devices and we all just
love battery life number two this makes
the parts of the screen that are
supposed to look black completely pitch
black so if you have like a black
notification bar on an android device
that literally looks like it's part of
the bezel it is completely black the
contrast is amazingly high on oled
screens and colors really pop which is
awesome and three the screen itself
since it doesn't need to have a
backlight is much thinner have you ever
noticed that oled display devices are
much thinner than their led counterparts
samsung galaxy s2 oled displays and
monitors the nexus s the zune hd hey i
propose every mobile manufacturer switch
over to oled displays as soon as
possible hit that like button if you
agree you can also hit up that link in
the description for all the info you
could ever wish to know about oled
technology it'll blow your mind that's
basically it for this video again if you
give it a thumbs up that's great mkbhd
signing out
peace
[Music]
you